bonsoir je vais vous poser une petite
devinette qu'est ce qui à votre avis
relis un pianiste libanais un
calligraphe coréen une compagnie de
ballet hip hop un grand professeur
américain de violon des écrivains
américains un percussionniste japonais
j'arrête là cet
cette liste à la prévert qui pourrait
être un peu trop longue bien ce qui
réunisse tous ces personnes ces
personnes tous ces artistes c'est un
petit village du limousin il ya 150
habitants et qui a la particularité
entre autres d'avoir deux églises une
église protestante et une église
catholique et entre les deux une grande
ferme qui a été bâti au début du 20e
siècle
c'est cette histoire un peu étrange que
je vais vous raconter maintenant c'est
une histoire qui mêle à la fois une
histoire familiale une histoire
religieuse une histoire d'utopie bref
c'est l'histoire de villefavard c'est
une histoire en quatre actes un peu
comme dans les opéras premier acte une
conversion la révolution française a
beaucoup marqué la société civile et
religieuse et au cours du 19ème siècle
il ya eu des courants plus schismatique
dans l'église et notamment un courant
qui s'appelait l'église catholique
française et qui dont le clergé
revendiquait de faire la messe en
français que ton clergé ne ne
reconnaissait pas l'autorité du pape et
qu'il souhaitait aussi une grande
séparation entre
l'enseignement laïcs et religieux ce
mouvement a été en 1842 sommé de rentrer
dans le giron de l'église catholique
traditionnelle et s'est vue interdite de
de culte c'est alors que le curé de
favard qui faisait partie de ce
mouvement et toute sa paroisse s'est
converti au protestantisme en effet
c'était beaucoup plus simple d'être
protestants parce qu'il était plus
proche de leur idéologie
enfin de ce qu'il voulait défendre que
finalement de l'église catholique
traditionnelle donc l'église de
villefavard devient protestante
alors on dit que toutes les familles de
villefavard s'était convertie sauf une
et donc les catholiques sont obligés de
construire une nouvelle église
deuxième acte arrive sur ces entrefaites
quelques années plus tard en 1883 un
pasteur un peu atypique qui est ce
pasteur et sa femme d'origine suisse il
reste peu de temps à villefavard mais
ont le temps de tisser avec la
population des liens profonds et
d'amitié perdureront quelques années
plus tard au début du 20e siècle en 1900
le pasteur revient dans avis favard il
vient d'hériter de moyens importants et
en l'espace de quatre ans il
il construit trois édifices un une belle
villa pour lui genre il a dû au bord du
lac léman puisque il fait appel pour ses
trois édifices à un architecte suisse
donc une belle villa pour lui il trouve
que l'ancienne église est vraiment
vétuste et trop petit il la rase et
construit un grand temple et enfin y
construit une grande ferme modèle
pour montrer aux et aux paysans de
l'époque les dernières nouveautés en
agriculture industrielle naissante
alors cette ferme et de très vastes
dimensions est autour d'une cour carrée
d'une cour pavée avec une fontaine
abreuvoir avec une grande grange pour
battre le blé les normes établies où il
y avait presque 60 vaches une énorme
porcherie 7,7
cette ferme utilise également des
techniques très innovante dans sa
construction
en effet on dit que c'est une des
premières fermes à utiliser du béton
armé dans ces structures
il y à un système de rails avec des
wagonnets du genre va mener de mines qui
amène la nourriture aux vaches et aux
cochons et enfin une système de captage
de sources
il permet d'avoir dans cette ferme l'eau
courante troisième acte
ils ont deux filles là l'aîné geneviève
est écrivain et elle épousera plus tard
le chef d'orchestre charles munch la
cadette
c'est juliette alors juliette est une
est très doué pour la musique elle est
très douée pour le violon elle recevra
les meilleurs professeurs de l'époque
l'enseignement des meilleurs professeurs
de l'époque son père lui achète deux
violons de très grande valeur dont l'un
un guarnerius tel jésus sera acheté plus
tard par menuhin
alors elle lui elle lui dira cher
monsieur je vous le vent mais vous
viendrez en personne le chercher chez
moi
deuxièmement vous viendrez faire un
concert une faveur juliette a la passion
de transmettre son amour pour la musique
à l'occasion
d'un transfert d'un orgue dans le temps
le temple elle organise un premier
concert où elle fait venir des artistes
de renom et surtout elle crée un coeur
avec les gens du village
ces concerts qui auront lieu chaque
année invitera - inviteront des artistes
de renom on verra par exemple maurice
andré le jeune trompettiste en culottes
courtes où on verra une des très grands
vers une liste des grandes chanteurs de
renom et surtout il ya cette ce coeur
qui se produit à chaque à chaque concert
c'est sur ce terreau que arrive le
quatrième acte dans les descendants de
juliette
il y a un chef d'orchestre et un
architecte il s'allie ensemble ils se
mettent ensemble pour acheter les
bâtiments de la ferme de l'arrière grand
père le chef d'orchestre invite des
jeunes musiciens au début leur carrière
pour alimenter le concert traditionnel
et très vite on s'aperçoit que le lieu
est propice à la concentration est
propice aux relations humaines etc
et au fond les musiciens souhaiterais
beaucoup pouvoir séjourner plus
longtemps ou revenir plus fréquemment
c'est de là que naît l'idée un peu
utopique de faire une salle de concert
pour remplacer le temple il était
pas forcément adaptées à ces concerts
est donc de faire une salle de concert
alors en france on n'est pas très porté
sur l'acoustique
en effet contrairement à certains pays
comme l'allemagne le holland là
l'angleterre la suisse il ya très peu de
salles de concerts qui sonne bien en
france et au fond quitte à faire une
salle de concert où tant qu'elle sonne
bien
donc on se met en quête de trouver un
bon acousticien on tombe sur albert ya
une chose qui est un acousticien de très
grande renommée qui est d'origine
chinoise à qui on doit les acoustiques
tout à fait remarquable de l'affairé
leur mini de luxembourg de copenhague de
l'opéra de pékin une nouvel opéra de
pékin est aussi de la grange des lacs à
evian a été construit pour mislav
rostropovitch on lui dit monsieur faites
nous un espèce de stradivarius pour
cette salle de concert en 2002 la salle
est inaugurée par trois concerts et on
envoie un petit communiqué de presse
disant villefavard 150 habitants
inaugure sa salle de 300 places
s'ils n'y ait pas d'effets des grands
acousticien actuelle le figaro reprend
le communiqué de presse dans un article
villefavard 150 habitants inaugure sa
salle de 300 places signé par un des
grandes acousticien actuelle paris 8
millions d'habitants n'est pas foutu
d'avoir une belle salle de concert
très vite cette salle de concert on
s'aperçoit qu'elle elle attire d'abord
un public tout à fait de proximité mais
un public tout à fait nombreux et
surtout elle est très vite repéré par
des labels discographiques et qui
viennent avec des
des grands artistes pour enregistrer
aussi des grands des groupes viennent
pour y travailler et donc il faut
parallèlement à cette salle de concert
développer un accueil pour que les gens
puissent rester en résidence et donc peu
à peu la ferme se transforment en lieux
d'accueil alors ce qui est très très
étonnant c'est que cette ferme qui avait
été fait pour l'agriculture et bien
finalement elle est parfaitement adaptée
à en fait à l'accueil
alors par exemple dans le poulailler au
mais l'administration dans le bûcher
grande cuisine dans l'est soit cochon la
salle de restauration
enfin bref tout ça se case très très
bien et on arrive à avoir donc une
structure d'accueil pour les résidents
alors c'est plus uniquement la musique
qui s'invita me savard mais c'est de
plus en plus des écrivains des
chorégraphes des danseurs des enfin il
ya une grande diversification et ça
devient un peu une fabrique de
spectacles qui se quittent pas de
villefavard et qui après sera donnée
ailleurs récemment par exemple un pôle
d'art vocal a été créé qui permet
d'avoir en résidence un choeur de jeunes
du limousin
il vient y travailler et ensuite
diffusés dans les écoles dans les
collèges dans les maisons de retraite
dans les hôpitaux
de leur art quelques chiffres très très
rapidement et 4,5 5 employés à l'année
6000 repas en moyenne par an 100 150 160
jours de résidence
donc c'est une petite entreprise qui
participe à l'animation économique de du
limousin et aussi à ce rayonnement
régional national voire international
en conclusion cette histoire a été au
fond c'est développer d'une manière
finalement très naturel en utilisant ce
que les les générations précédentes
avaient su créer et transmettre plus
récemment 7 c
elle a été aidée par des très grands
professionnels je pense à ma femme par
exemple qui a été très très importante
dans l'élaboration cette histoire en
conclusion le cette ferme qui a été
construite par un pasteur un peu
utopique qui est venu à l'issue d'un
conflit religieux a finalement réalisé
une nouvelle utopie à savoir faire venir
du monde entier les artistes de très
haut niveau pour y venir travailler
créer transmettre leur savoir et
accrocher leurs rêves
l'histoire n'est pas que je n'ai pas
terminé elle continue je vous remercie